Prince Harry will marry American actress
Megan Marco in England in just three
days he is the youngest child of Prince
Charles and Princess Diana and sixth in
line to the throne Prince Harry served
in the British Army and is known for his
philanthropic work but when he was
growing up he had a reputation for being
a royal rebel this Saturday millions
will tune in to watch the wedding just
like on the day he was born destined for
life in the spotlight crowds gathered in
London to celebrate the arrival of His
Royal Highness Prince Henry of Wales
Prince Henry will be known as Harry
there was such tremendous excitement
when Prince Harry was born
Amandla Foreman is a royal historian you
could say that Prince Harry was born
under a lucky star a happy star
genuinely thrilled he arrived
according to Princess Diana her youngest
son set his own path early on whether he
copies William we wait and see but he's
certainly different character altogether
as the world watched William and Harry
grow up the images were often of the
boys enjoying time with their mother I
brought the picture of you okay all
those years ago Harry looked back on his
first visit to the United States when he
spoke with us in 2016
you know we had happy happy memories you
know it was it was absolutely fantastic
a year after her marriage to Prince
Charles came to an end
Diana known as the most photographed
woman in the world was killed in a car
crash after a high-speed chase with
paparazzi in Paris he and his brother
think the media killed their mother just
to be clear Tom Bradby is a British
broadcaster and a friend of William and
Harry I don't mean sort of
metaphorically I mean literally
let's talk about the boys being told
that they had to walk behind their
mothers funeral procession British I've
always had a sentimental side to them
and they've throughout history really
loved long torturous funeral processions
and the two boys were forced to take
part in this charade both been on record
saying how terrible how painful it was
to be forced to walk past thousands
hundreds of thousands of people all
staring at their faces wanting to drink
their emotions like vampires drinking
Bloods and that they had to control
themselves with privacy rarely assured
cameras caught Prince Harry in several
scandals as he grew older and that came
to a terrible head when he was a
teenager we went to a party dressed as a
Nazi officer and there's no doubt in
anyone's mind that Prince Harry was not
a Nazi sympathizer he was just being an
idiot but you can't afford to be an
idiot when you're you know the next in
line to the throne after your elder
brother the discipline of a soldier came
when Harry joined the British Army in
2005 as an officer he did two tours in
Afghanistan and became the first royal
to see combat in a quarter century it's
very nice to be out of out of touch from
everything it's probably the nicest bit
about this place after a decade of
service Prince Harry left the army but
continued to fight for the wounded men
and women of the military by creating
the Invictus games
I've seen the way Prince Harry interacts
with veterans it's so incredibly genuine
he has a real connection it's amazing
because you can't make up a sense of
connection one can say well you know his
mother also had a connection with the
wounded with the vulnerable with people
who don't haven't yet developed the
defenses of this world what do you think
your mother Princess Diana would think
about what you've done
here for veterans I I'd hope she being
incredibly proud I would love it if she
was here and I'm sure she would be
running around causing chaos like I
intend to what's really ironic about
Princess Diana is that she came from the
top echelon of society yet she herself
was in many ways increasingly a social
rebel so for her son to carry on that
tradition would have no doubt NATO and
set exceptionally proud his marriage to
Megan Markel may be a sign the
rebellious Prince is settling down
something not even Harry was willing to
predict two years ago do you want to
have kids someday I know from that
question to that of course you know who
doesn't you know time you know time time
time will tell and I'm looking forward
to the opportunity pretty busy at the
moment
engines come wait wait that was before
Megan Marco that was before Megan we all
remember that video was so sad to see
them walking behind their mother's
casket and to see how he's turned out is
really exciting he seems very much like
his mom doesn't he I know and you know
that's interesting to hear the historian
talked about him being sort of
rebellious like his mother but and I
have to tell you you know we meet a lot
of people doing the show he is one of
the most off-center and charming and
relaxed people I've ever met given that
he grew up in front of the cameras the
way he did and to have his mother passed
the way she did yeah it's amazing you
know and you think about what we're
celebrating here is this family these
people but it also there's a stretch of
lineage I mean you think of Prince Hal
right the story of a prince who grows up
a rebel and then becomes more serious is
as old as English literature so a lot of
tradition there
now that I think he's a rebel I think
now I'm starting I think he might have
his beard Gail I have a bet on that I
know well I think he's gonna have it you
say does he know it's a crack in my
confident era T's gonna benefit yeah
that's right